one of the most overrated lightweights
to take a term from trump's vocabulary
is former uh south carolina governor
and former trump ambassador to the
united nations
nikki haley nikki haley wasted no time
in appearing on
farcical newsmax hosted by
by sean spicer yeah that sean spicer
trump's pathetic
former press secretary sean spicer and
she
went on to talk to sean spicer on
newsmax rehabilitating the
same tired predictable talking points
that i've been telling you for a year
now
would instantly reappear when a democrat
is sworn into office and donald trump
leaves now a year ago we didn't even
know
which democrat it might be that replaces
donald trump
but it didn't matter no matter which
democrat
replaced trump they would go oh
dead in deficit we can't afford this
we can't afford that the far left
socialists are taking over we knew what
the playbook was going to be
and here is nikki haley playing her role
saying that joe biden's far-left foreign
policy
is going to be very dangerous listen to
her
answer after sean spicer manages to
cough
out this softball question you have this
new op-ed out
that you talk about the democrats going
leftward but i want to talk about this
in the context
of biden and his foreign policy
specifically
who he's appointed and who in the
policies that he's going to pursue
can you kind of talk about where you
think uh
the biden foreign policy and the biden
personnel picks are going to go
direction-wise i mean look i'm i'm not
gonna lie i'm extremely concerned about
um what's going on you've got iran
they're in the process of producing
nuclear weapons and here biden wants to
get back into the iran deal
she's very concerned by
notice the idiocy of what she says she
says
look iran is producing nuclear weapons
and biden wants back into the deal
don't let them trick you okay first of
all iran is resuming resuming research
into nuclear
they're not producing weapons yet but
they could but what she's saying is not
true but yes
iran is resuming research why is iran
resuming research into nuclear power and
nuclear uh
energy which could be used for weapons
iran is doing that
because they abided by the nuclear deal
that barack obama struck with them
trump came into office and simply
canceled it without iran having done
anything wrong so of course as i told
you the day trump did this that iran was
going to go back to nuclear research and
they did
the iran deal was the only thing keeping
iran from doing the nuclear research
and now nikki haley is already blaming
biden
for wanting to get back into the deal
which was actually working to stop iran
from developing
is this bad faith or is nikki that
ignorant i have a really hard time
believing that nikki haley
is this ignorant i assume that this is
just bad faith pandering
to a radical newsmax audience that
doesn't know any better
let's listen to a little bit more of
this when you look at his
picks for cabinet and otherwise i mean
from john kerry to susan rice
you you don't have to be you know that
much of a historian to know where this
is going and i think this is going to be
to the left of obama i think we need to
hold on to our wallet and i think we
need to
stop with all of the the finger pointing
and that he said she said and we've got
to get to work
this is this is gonna hurt and we need
to really be focused on where we're
gonna go from here
isn't that just outrageous and pathetic
john
kerry and susan rice completely
uncontroversial milk toast
moderate democrats nothing radical about
john kerry and susan rice nothing
socialist about them
john kerry very smart more than well
qualified
understands climate issues these are the
far
left scary people now john kerry
is far left now and then of course she
says
we've got to hold on to our wallets what
you might be wondering what is she
talking about
trump exploded the deficit more than any
recent president
more than obama more than bush clinton
had a surplus never mind
what is she talking about the stimulus
and infrastructure spending that biden
wants
is much needed it generates revenue by
creating jobs and putting money back
into the hands of small businesses so
i i hate that i'm right about this i
hate that i was right and many of you
were as well you emailed me and said
david they're going back to dead and
deficit and all of this stuff
they aren't even waiting for joe biden
to be sworn in
to get back to the pathetic talking
points that we had a four-year break
from
the question is are the same right
wingers
going to fall for these same talking
points again
or has the ship sailed remains to be
seen
but there is going to be plenty of this
on fox news
on oan and on newsmax and it is going to
take
everything we have to take a group that
has already
they're already so in need of
deprogramming
and now you're going to see newsmax and
oan scale up and maybe you'll see
fox news do it as well to try to keep up
with them it's going to be a very much
uphill battle and they are wasting no
time